weather's going to be fun it's going to
be a real treat for trick-or-treaters
this weekend let's check valley
temperatures this morning we're dipping
down into the 50s just about everywhere
now it is cool enough for long sleeves
to get you out the door 30s up in
caliani indian springs you should be
dropping into at least some upper 40s by
now 50s in mesquite low 60s for boulder
city 73 in laughlin and 39 up there in
reno they get those cool nights that's
why my kid moved up there to go to
school i just want to get away from the
heat so it's going to be a great game
good luck to both schools of course both
teams we've got the pacific northwest
that's where the storm track is with the
jet stream and so there will be showers
from seattle down to portland but pretty
much staying in oregon and just clipping
northern california nevada should stay
in the clear in the desert southwest
will stay under a ridge of high pressure
to deliver extra warm weather for us all
the way through the weekend
big showers this is a huge area of low
pressure spinning in the eastern half of
the u.s showers isolated thunderstorms a
lot of unstable air in some areas likely
that some of these are going to have
some embedded severe storms today so i
really wish wish them well over there
during the storm 62 for mount charleston
beautiful hiking weather light winds for
all of us 80 degrees
for our friday afternoon we were 81
yesterday 75 as normal now laughlin has
been keeping some north winds over the
last couple of days and they're still
blowing along the river all right let's
see how creepy it's going to be for the
trick-or-treaters
i don't know anybody can complain about
this unless your costume's too warm
we're talking 79 at 5 00 p.m sunday 76
into the evening hours and by nine
o'clock most kids probably should be
home and get into bed by then after
eating a few their treats of course low
70s wow it is going to be warm so pick
out some cool costumes
low 80s for saturday clouds saturday
night sunshine on sunday and we start
off november with mid 70s and some
clouds around no rain though in the
eight day forecast